but in the mix lying for mr. Trump is  normalized and no one around him  questioned it in fairness no one around  him today questions it either a lot of  people have asked me about whether mr.  Trumbull knew about the release of the  hacked documents the Democratic National  Committee emails ahead of time and the  answer is yes as I earlier stated mr.  Trump knew from Roger stone in advance  about the WikiLeaks drop of emails in  July of 2016  days before the Democratic convention I  was in mr. Trump's office when his  secretary announced that Roger stone was  on the phone mr. Trump mr. stone on the  speakerphone mr. stone told mr. Trump  that he had just gotten off the phone  with Julian Assange and that mr. Assange  told mr. stone that within a couple of  days there would be a massive dump of  emails that would damage Hillary  Clinton's campaign mr. Trump responded  by stating to the effect wouldn't that  be great